[拍手]
説明することをですね皆さんにお伝えし
ながら後ろの今スライドに出てます何か
ワクワクすることを今日から始めませんか
ということですねお話しさせていただき
たいと思います私がですねわくわくする
ことなんですが実はですね
プロジェクションマッピングなんです本当
にあの素人なんですが
自分のですね持ってるタブレットであると
かスマホとかを使って学校さん学校の
先生方先生とさんと
校舎にでいろんな場所にですね東映の方を
してきました
でプロジェクションマッピングのいい
ところはですね見慣れた風景が一変するん
ですね
普段見慣れてる建物とかが全く違うものに
なってその建物にいろんなストーリーを
描くことができるんです
でプロジェクションマッピングって私も
やり始めた時そうだったんですけど初めは
ですね大変そうだとか難しいんじゃないの
とか特殊な
教育を受けた方特別な人じゃないとでき
ないんじゃないかと思ってたんですねです
けども実際やってみると
タブレットとか学校のプロジェクターです
ね今もそこに写ってるプロジェクターより
ちっちゃいやつでも
校舎に
投影することができるんです
で私なんですけど
もともとはですね
タブレットに入ってました
プレゼンソフトを使ってこういった
アニメーションを作ってたんですね教材用
のそこでこれできるんじゃないかとこの
アニメーション作れるんだったら
タブレットでプロジェクションマッピング
できないかと思ったんです
そうしているうちに
やりたいぞっていう風になりましたででも
私サボり症なんで
いつまでだってやらないんですねだから
自分を追い詰めなくちゃいけないと思い
ました
SNSでみんなのこう人私と友達の前です
ねやるぞと何回も言ったので引き下がれ
ない状況を作ったんですね
で2016年初めはですねこの100均で
買ったこのちっちゃいフィギュアから
プロデューションマッピングをしました
ちっちゃいLEDのですねプロジェクター
で投影してできると次がですね
Amazonで買ったですねこういうこの
狐のお面なんですねそこに投影しましたで
1年後全然その家とか校舎とかすっ飛ばし
てお城になったんですねいきなりこれやっ
た時をすごかったですどうしようかと
依頼された時思いましたもともとはですね
新しくできた後者の方に投影してください
ということだったんでまだ何とかなるかな
と思ってたんですけどいやいやさん近くに
あのお城あってお城の許可取れたんでお城
でよろしくお願いしますって言われてです
ね私はド素人ですあの皆さん見てもらっ
てるようにお面までしかやったことない
人間がいきなりあのお城で共有しろという
話になったんで驚きました開き直ったん
ですね
誰もやっていない方法で誰もやっていない
ことやってみようという風に思いました
開き直りましたそしてですね
広げて
任せてくださいよ私やりますよと広げて
ですね自分の可能性を広げてやると
失敗したらごめんなさいと謝ろうと思って
ました心の中ですごくこう罪悪感とやって
やるぞという気持ちをこうね
挟まれてたんですけどもで実際いろいろ
やってみましたもう例えば今だったらAI
に聞けばわかるかもしれないですけど
ネットでお城にプロジェクション
マッピングする方法であるとか本で
プロジェクションマッピングを使用する
方法なんてどこにも書いてなかったんです
ねなのでいろんな方のお力をお借りして
プロジェクターの設置位置
電源の取り方どういう風に打ち合わせする
かっていうのも1から
検証していきましたすごく学びになったん
ですね0からやったことなんで絶対忘れ
ないですはいでいろいろですね東映の方を
やってみますとこのような形で行けそう
だっていうに行けたのでもうただもう12
月に投決まってたんでそのスケジュールに
こう
毎日こう胃を痛めながらですねこう見えて
また繊細なんですけど
繊細な私が追い詰められていったわけです
で実際にこういった作ってきましたで
プロジェクションマッピングって建物の形
に合わせて投影しますので建物の形が
いわゆるこのスクリーンなんですね
スクリーンの形となりますそれに合わせた
絵作りっていうのをしていくんだという
ことを作りながら学んでいったというよう
な感じでした
はい
初めてですね
投影された件もうもうドキドキワクワクし
たんですねもう止まらなかったんですこの
いいおじさんがですねもう止まらないと
いう風になりましたそしてあの大阪のおっ
ちゃんなんで非常におせっかいとこがあっ
てですね変な使命感が出てきたんですね
若い方にこのドキドキとワクワクをやって
もらいたいというふうにこう押し付け
おかしい勝手な使命感が湧いてきたんです
そしていろんなところにこう問い合わせを
受けたりですねやってみませんかとお話を
していって小学校でもですね小学生の
パソコンクラブの方々も実際に校舎に
プロジェクションマッピングをしたりお寺
にするようになりましたそして
京都の学校さんでは礼拝堂にクリスマスの
時期にやるようになりましたしはいこれね
あの愛知県にあるあのお菓子の城っていう
テーマパークの建物があるんですそこで
やったんですけどこれプロがやったら
かなりお金をかかるもんなんですけど実は
僕も驚いたんですけど
火をただでやってますでどういう風になっ
たかというと建物大体70mぐらいの幅が
あるんですねでそれを一つの
プロジェクターでじゃあ抑えきれないので
3つのプロジェクターで場所をですね分け
てやっていきましたそして普通プロであれ
ば一つのボタンを押したらですねボンと3
つ一斉に動くんですけど僕たち素人なんで
1世のでやるよポンとしてスタートすると
で最初ちょっとずれちゃったんでもう1回
やり直しをしたんですけど皆さん画面見て
気がつきませんか
段ボール箱の上にプロジェクター持ってる
んですね
で見ていただくとですね本当に教室に置い
ているプロジェクターを3つ使ってやって
ますこれいろんな条件があって建物が
真っ白だからというのと工場地帯で飲んで
周りが真っ黒なんですごく鮮やかに映っ
たっていうところでこれが実現したんです
ねですので今あるものですごいことが
できるんだってことを教えていただきまし
た逆に
でこの地域のですねプロジェクション
マッピングというのがだんだん形作られて
きまして学校の今あるICT機器ですね
プロジェクターとかタブレット等を使って
学生さんがですね地域と連携して
プロジェクションマッピングを行うという
形がどんどんできてきたんです
で
ちょうどこのコロナで外出制限ももうが
あってですね僕も現地行けなくてずっと
こうテレビのオンライン会議で教えて
打ち合わせをしてやった岩手県の沼宮内と
いうところがありますこちらの方はかなり
人口が少なくなってきてましてですね若い
方がどんどん出ていくとで神話で有名な
場所なんですね沼宮内っていう地域もです
ね神話から捉えた名前らしいんですで住吉
さんプロジェクターが教室にある1個しか
ないとで夏が夏にやりたいんだけど外で
やるのもこう台も組めないし天気が悪く
なったらどうしようという話だったんで
みんなと話し合って美術館のリニューアル
だったんで2階のところから床に投影
しようよってことでやりましたすごく
アートな作品ができたんですね
学生さんたちともう知恵を絞れば何でも
できるんだっていう風にこちらで思いまし
た
で私が本当にこのプロジェクション
マッピングやってて良かったなと思ったの
がですね若い方々による地域の魅力の再
発見なんですね例えばプロの方にお願いし
てプロジェクションマッピングやってうわ
すごかったねって終わるとそれで終わっ
ちゃうんですけど若い方々がやっぱこう
投影するってなると内容を考えなくちゃ
いけないじゃあ自分の地域のいいところは
どこだろうかっていうのを再確認するん
ですね例えば大阪の私が通天閣行ったこと
がないように
意外と地元が行ったことがない気づいて
ない良さっていうのがあるんですそれを
発見していただけると若い方に加えて
魅力をですね若い方から発信して
いただけるということがやっぱりこう当事
者意識を持って自分たちの地域の魅力を
発信するということは素晴らしいなと思い
ました
気づいたことがあるんですそれは変化なん
ですね私も皆さんに教えてもらってすごく
変化したんですけどそれ以上にですね若い
方々がですね
初めめっちゃ人見知りだったんですよ私が
オンラインで喋りかけてももう目も
オンラインなど合わせにずらいんですけど
なかなか反応がないと聞いてもらってるの
が不安だなと思ってたような人見知りの子
たちがですねどんどん積極的に大人と
しゃべるようになったんですねなぜかと
いうと例えば市役所の方との調整であると
かもしくはその学校とかですね近隣の企業
の方にご協力を煽るためにいろいろと自分
たちでこう発信して話をしていかなくちゃ
いけないんですけど初めはあのクラスで今
まで女の子と喋ったことがないっていう
男の子がいたんですけどねそれがもう
プロジェクションマッピング終わった頃に
はですねもう取材なりしてて新聞社と
テレビ社の曲も一緒に平気でしゃべって
るって見た時は人って変わるんだなという
風に驚かせていただきました
そして生徒さんたちの感想もですねいくつ
か紹介したいと思います
やはり大きなですね外部の
施設イベントを行ったので
責任感やですね周りへの気遣いができる
ようになったというところとやったり
コミュニケーション能力ですね先ほど
申し上げた部分が向上したというところも
ありますで人前に出ること自信がつい
たっていうところですねで積極性やっぱり
自分から動かないと何も動かないっていう
ことを学んでくれたようですごくあの積極
性が向上したって言われましたそして
何よりもやっぱ嬉しかったのが見に来て
くれた友達ですねよく知ってる方々先輩と
かですねあとおばあちゃんからとかですね
よかったよとか面白かったよすごいねって
いうことで
喜んでもらいたんですね皆さんもそうだと
思うんですけど
年を取るたびにですね
褒められることってめちゃくちゃ少なく
なると思うんですだから不安で結構
いろんなことに手を出したりするしてたん
ですけど僕もでもプロジェクション
マッピングで生徒さんもそうですし僕も
そうですけどやったらできると喜んで
もらえるって事ですごく自己肯定感が
上がったんですねすごくすごい発見でした
やって良かったなと思いました
そして何よりも答えがないんです
ゼロからですね自分たちで
企画を考えてどこに投影するどんな内容で
誰に向けてっていう風に考えて
ゼロから想像する学びがあるっていうのが
分かりました若い方々もそうですけど大人
の僕からしてもいつも学ばさせてもらって
ますもうケースバイケースなんで場所がで
そこの地域の
文化とか伝統も教えてもらってますすごく
学びになるって事が分かりましたでやり
きる力ですね最後までイベントを成功さ
せる力っていうのはやっぱりこう大人も
子供もですね非常にこう学ぶところであっ
てこのやりきり力って即大事だと思って
ます
そしてですねある先生が言っておられまし
た住吉さんプロジェクションマッピングっ
て圧倒的達成感ありますよねということで
なんかもうお祭りなんですねもうそこに
至るまでの苦労があるんですよチームで
こう言い合ったりとか企画を考えて分裂も
してでも最後見える形で他の人たち喜んで
もらえるって時も本当に続々とですね
圧倒的達成感があるということがわかった
んです
で人生が変わる可能性がありますという
ことで私が実際こうやって皆さんにお話し
できてもこのプロジェクションマッピング
あったからなんですけど2年前に
プロジェクトに参加していただいた生徒
さんからですね連絡がありました
大学のですねこれこれをやった
プロジェクションマッピングをやったって
いう実績をもとに
推薦が取れたであるとかもしくは
興味を持ったんで自分で勉強しましてそう
いう系の学校行きますって話になりました
もしかすると僕が関わった生徒さんの中で
10年後20年後すごい映画監督生まれ
てるかもしれないと思うとゾクゾクするん
ですね
楽しいと思いましたそしてですねまあ大人
がいつまでもあぐら書いててはいけません
新しいチャレンジしなくちゃと思いました
で私がやり始めたのですねCG
政策ですね実は
有名なソフトで無料でプロレベルの作業が
できるCGソフトってあるんです普通の
パソコンで動くんですけどそれを使って
この私実は50超えてるんですけども50
超えたおっちゃんがですね1からちょっと
CGをやり始めてみました初めは
YouTubeの動画を見ながらで12
ヶ月すると作品ができるようになってきた
んですねできるんだと僕でもできるんだと
思いましたそしてですねこの映像をCD
作った映像をプロジェクト
プロジェクションマッピング素材にして
いこうという風に考えましたで私絵が描け
ないんです全く下手なんですねもう子供
から見てもあの小1の娘会社の下手って私
より下手って言われるんですけど
絵が描けなくてもCGだったら15分
ぐらいでこれ作れちゃうんですね
作れちゃうんですだから本当に僕こんな
能力ないと思ったんですけどあできるんだ
びっくりしました
プラモデル作り早いんですね色塗ったり
こう台と仕込んだりということを考えると
でCGならアニメーションも簡単なんです
ね最近作ったやつなんですけど基本のある
素材を使って動きを取り込んでこんな感じ
でアニメーションが実はこう簡単に物理
シュミレーションであるとかこういった
ちょっとこうあのアクションみたいなやつ
とかも実は作れるこれ私作ったんですよ嘘
じゃないですよあの50を超えておっ
ちゃんのこんなが作れるという感じですね
なのでこういったCGアニメーションで
プロジェクションマッピングをさらにこう
質を上げていけないかと思いましたで実際
にですねお寺ほせんさんというお寺がある
んですけど
プレッションマッピングする際にちょっと
チャレンジさせてくれということで実際に
このCGで作ったもの投影してみました
行けましたできるなっていう風に分かり
ましたでほんのですね
些細な挑戦
このフィギュアからですね
プロジェクションマッピングをしようと
こんな挑戦からですねこんなとこまで自分
ができるんだいろんな地域のこうイベント
になるんだってわかってですね認識が
大きく変化したんですそして学校の児童
生徒さんがですねCG制作できるよと
めちゃくちゃ面白いんじゃないかという風
に考えましたですごいことが起こるんじゃ
ないかと思いましたんで
私の
娘小学校1年生で4月から2年生になるん
ですけどCG政策を1回体験させようと
やってました30分ぐらい教えたらですね
ロボットの顔見た作り出したんですねそれ
から半年後です
私の想像の遥か斜めを上を行ったんですね
半年後オリジナルアバターを作られました
びっくりしましたもう僕と似て
ドジっ娘なんですけど
すごく可能性は子供さん秘めてるんだなと
いうふうにわかりましたこれはいけると
いうことで実際ですね小学校さんの向けて
オンラインでつないでこのCD制作の交渉
をやってみたんですけど2時間ぐらいで
生徒さんできましたすごいなと思いました
じゃあ先生はってことでなんか大人って
こういうの苦手だって住之江さんたまたま
できるだけだよって言われるかなと思った
んでやってみたんですね90分の9時から
10時半の講習で夜の先生方が全くこの
CGソフト初めてなのにガラスの支持この
グラスに入った氷の支持作りなんですね
いやできるすごい可能性みんな秘めてるな
と思ったんです
人の変化と可能性をですね知った時にです
ね身近な例えばスマホやタブレットそして
無料のCDソフトなどを使ってすごい人も
人の変化を見ました可能性を感じたんです
ですので僕をドキドキとワクワクですね
こういうことをやって止まらないんですね
でもし
絵を描くようにCGで映像を制作できたら
ワクワクしませんか僕はワクワクしますで
もやっぱ人によって好き嫌いでやりたい
ことって違うと思いますですので人
それぞれのワクワク僕はワクワク可能性
って言い換えてる部分もあるんですけど人
それぞれ皆さんがやっぱりこうやってみ
たいなやろうと思ってたんだ若い頃に今
友達がやってる方いろいろあると思います
皆さんにとってですね一応ちょっと考えて
ほしいんです今日来た
こともご縁ですしワクワクすることは何
ですかパッと思い浮かべてくださいなんか
すごいことをしなくていいんです最初は
ネットで調べるだけでもいいですし
友達にこれやってみたいんだって言うだけ
でも宣言するだけでもいいですしメモで
書き出してもいいですほんのちょっとの
ですね一歩からですねものすごく変わると
思います
皆さんにおすすめしたいのは最初の冒頭
ですね何かワクワクすることを今日から
始めてみませんかということになります見
慣れた風景がですね一変する
プロジェクションマッピングと同じように
皆さんが見てる風景がですね
ごろっと変わるきっかけになるかもしれ
ません今はいろんな機材SNSですとか
いろんなものに
恵まれててすごく可能性がある時代です
ですのでこれをうまく使って皆さんの人生
をですねより豊かにより楽しくワクワク
するようにですねしていただけたら嬉しい
と思いますはい私のようになって
いただけると
偉そうですけど偉そうには言わないです
けど本当に楽しいですからはいということ
をお伝えしたいと思いまして今日はお話を
させていただきましたはいありがとう
ございました
[拍手]